easy arancini delicious golden rice
balls
[Music]
first chop mozzarella into small cubes
then take handfuls of leftover risotto
add a cube of mozzarella and fold into a
ball around the cheese
[Music]
perfect with leftover mushroom risotto
but it's great with any risotto
for the coating prep three bowls one
with flour one with breadcrumbs and one
with beaten egg
to each arancini first into the flour
then the egg wash and finally the
breadcrumbs then in a pan heat the olive
oil and Fry the arancini into golden
brown
drain and serve simply with lemon
easy arancini a delicious tempting treat
that's great for leftovers and Cooks in
under 10 minutes